the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie what's up ladies and
gentlemen welcome back for another Game
of Thrones Season eight video since the
new Game of Thrones trailer still has
everyone excited I want to make another
video based on some of the things we
could see as you all know there are
hundreds or even thousands of theories
on the internet about Game of Thrones a
in A Song of Ice and Fire in fact I have
even made a bunch of those videos myself
as fans of the show I think we all like
to try to figure out how some of the
different storylines within the show
will come to an end well thanks to the
new trailer we may have some more
evidence that supports some of these
theories or predictions what I want to
do today is take another look at some of
the images from the trailer that
supports these theories at the end of
the video let me know which ones you
think are most likely to come true the
first theory I want to talk about has to
do with our old friend ginjury I
actually made a video about this over
two years ago in the new Game of Thrones
trailer we can see ginjury working in
the forges of Winterfell as of right now
we know ginjury will be making weapons
out of the dragon glass from Dragonstone
we can see the dragon glass laying all
around ginjuries workshop he was most
likely the one that made the new dragon
glass dagger we can see Arya Stark
holding up in the trailer now if you
look and listen very carefully during
ginjury scene in the trailer you can see
that ginjury is making more than just
dragon glass weapons
it looks like Genji might be making a
new sword now the million-dollar
question is will Genji make any weapons
out of Valyrian steel now we all know
that the methods to maken brand new
Valyrian steel have either been lost or
forgotten over time however we have seen
someone reforge it before Tywin
Lannister was able to find someone to do
this when Ned Stark's Valyrian steel
sword ice in the television show Tywin
Lannister said the blacksmith he hired
was from volantis which just so happens
to be the same place Melisandre was
heading during last season now in the
books the character that Ari forges ice
is actually the same man that gantry
worked for which is topo Motte
don't you find that to be just a little
interesting
I know I do since Gendry cement or knew
how to rework Valyrian steel
this leads many fans including myself to
believe there might have been a very
good chance he might have shown or at
least told ginjury how to do this too
after all Gendry is robert baratheon son
which obviously makes him a very
important character even if he's not one
of the main characters why would you
have ginjury work for one of the very
few men who knew how to rework Valyrian
steel unless you were gonna have ginjury
make some later in the story now as I
said before unfortunately Game of
Thrones decided to change that in their
show ginjuries mentor was not the one
that reforged dice however there are
still a few ways they can have Ken jury
do this obviously the first thing we
would need to happen is Gendry needs to
get his hands on what is well in
Oathkeeper well luckily both of those
swords will be in Winterfell next season
at the same time Brienne is already
there with hers and as we all know Jaime
Lannister is currently on his way there
with the other half of ice now we all
know that the two swords are usually
better than one especially when it comes
to ice because of that sword was just
too damn big it would be very hard for
someone to carry a sword of that size
into battle unless you were one of the
damn claw game brothers so it might not
make that much sense to turn these two
swords into one right before the big
battle however this is something they
can do after all the fighting is over
assuming they are able to defeat the
army of the dead and Cersei and Euron
then maybe that's when the Starks could
get their sword back we have already
seen Jaime give a Valyrian steel sword
away once before so there is a good
chance that he could do it again Jaime
probably already feels bad for trying to
murder bran Stark and now that he's
trying to do the right thing he might do
the right thing with the sword - not to
mention there is always a chance that
Jaime could die then of course someone
would have to claim that sword now when
it comes to Brienne she has already
pledged her sword to House Stark once
the fighting is over maybe she gives it
back to Sansa or House Stark in general
that's assuming Brienne doesn't die -
now if Jaime and Brienne both died then
it would make it kinda easy for the
Starks to get the swords back so just
for the sake of this video let's say
they did get both of the swords back we
still need a way for Gendry to know how
to reforge them how would Genji learn
how to do this if his mentor did not
teach him in the show well there are
actually three different
I think they could do this the first way
has to do with brand stark as we all
know bran is able to look back in time
and see just about anything that he
wants
maybe bran could go back and see how
Valyrian steel was made we know that
dragons are involved in the process to
some extent other than that we really
don't know what else it takes to make
these swords from scratch now the good
thing is Danny already has two dragons
so if they would need a dragon fire to
do this I'm sure Daenerys wouldn't have
a problem helping another way they could
have Gendry learned this is through
Samwell Tarly as we all know right as
Sam was getting ready to leave the
Citadel he went into the library and he
grabbed a bunch of books and documents
to take with him he knew that these
things would help him and John during
the battle against than I came now we
don't know what's inside of them yet but
maybe Sam comes across the method to
make in Valyrian steel Sam might even
find it in the books then tell bran to
go back and look to see exactly how it
was done then they could just tell
Gendry what to do
the other option has to do with
Melisandre like I said earlier we know
Melisandre was on her way to volantis
and that's the same location Tywin found
his blacksmith to melt down ice and
remake it into two swords we know that
Melisandre did not go over there just to
take a vacation Melisandre is on a
mission to find someone or something to
help them defeat the night King until we
find out what that is maybe one of those
things she figures out is how to make
more Valyrian steel or maybe she even
brings back a blacksmith that knows how
I know that some of you have heard me
talk about this and some of my old
videos but after the new trailer came
out I had to talk about it again because
we do see Kendra making weapons but most
importantly we saw Gendry making a new
sword let me know if you think House
Stark will get Iced back by the end of
the show let's move on to the next one
now I want to talk about Jon Snow riding
a dragon this is one of those ideas that
has been around for a very long time
well they finally did confirm that jon
was a Targaryen in the television show
not only did we find out he was a
Targaryen but we also found out he is no
longer a bastard because Rhaegar and
Lyanna did get married now that we know
John is a Targaryen it seems natural for
him to start to have a relationship with
two dragons we actually started to see
this right away John and drogon had a
nice scene together last season we even
got to see several characters right on
drogon with Daenerys when they went
beyond the wall
but we still haven't seen John snow
climb on top of a dragon yet well Danny
only has two dragons left one of those
dragons just so happens to be named
after Jon Snow's daddy which is regal in
the new trailer we can see Jon and
Daenerys walking up to both of the
dragons it almost looks like they are
out in the middle of nowhere we also
don't see anyone else in that scene so
you have to wonder how did Jon and
Daenerys get there did they fly the
Dragons to that location because I don't
see any horses around them so maybe they
were both taking a dragons for a ride
there is another scene in the trailer
where we can see both of the dragons
flying together I've noticed that some
fans actually think Jon and Daenerys are
riding on their backs
only HBO had them digitally removed from
the scene that way it doesn't ruin it
I'm not so sure if that's the case but I
do think it's time for John to ride a
dragon as far as we know John and Danny
are there to last or gariands left they
are even in a relationship together and
in what makes sense for both of these
Targaryen to be riding the last two
living dragons that would be symmetry
ladies and gentlemen it was also
revealed that John's true name is Aegon
Targaryen and what do we know about one
of the most famous Aegon Targaryen z'
well we know that he wrote a dragon
among many other things so I believe
there is a very good chance that this
will happen but let me know what you
think because the trailer might have
been giving us some more evidence now I
want to move on to one of the other
scenes from the trailer this next one
has to do what ghost
Nymeria and her pack now as you all know
we hardly ever get to see the direwolves
anymore we did get to see Nymeria last
season but there was no sign of ghost
this has made a lot of fans including
myself very upset we all know that it
cost a lot of money to bring those
animals to life but ghosts should be
like an extension of John whenever John
is in Winterfell we should see ghosts at
least every once in a while well I think
the showrunners have heard our
complaints because they made sure to
remind us we will see ghosts next season
now when it comes to Nymeria things are
a little different
she hasn't been at arias side since the
second episode of the show not to
mention Aria was gone from Westeros for
a very long time so I do understand why
we haven't seen Nymeria and so long now
that Arya is back in Winterfell and
already reunited when I'm Ariel once
this makes most of us
wonder if we will ever see them together
again now we did see Aria try to get
Nymeria to go home with her but she has
become too wild
just like Aria however that doesn't mean
she won't show up again once Winterfell
comes under attack
Nymeria might start to get the sense
that aria is in trouble therefore she
might show up during the battle in fact
some fans think there was even a scene
of her in the trailer there is a scene
from the trailer where we can see
everyone starting to run back inside of
the castle gates during all of that
chaos there looks to be a scene where we
can see the horses running as well but
some fans think that could actually be
Nymeria and her pack now I can't really
be too sure what that is but I have
noticed some fans I said that the
stomach's of those animals are way too
low to the ground to be horses I will
say that is a very interesting
observation but let me show you
something else the author of the
original story said something during an
interview that may or may not confirm
that when George RR Martin's set down
with Mashable he said something about
Nymeria that had me very excited George
said you know I don't like to give
things away says Martin Agron spreading
across his face but you don't hang a
giant wolf pack on the wall unless you
intend to use it what George basically
said is of course Nymeria and her pack
will show up why else would you
introduce that into the story unless you
wanted to use it so if this is what
George wants to do at the end of his
story then maybe Game of Thrones does
the same thing maybe there is a good
reason why they shown Aria and Nymeria
reunite last season that could be
foreshadowing for an even bigger scene
next season let me know if you think
that's what we see in the trailer I'm
not so sure myself but I do think they
could show up during the battle as we
all know Aria and I Miriah do have a
special connection
so if aria does find herself in some
serious trouble which we know she does
based on some of the other scenes from
the trailer then maybe Nymeria shows up
to try to save her anyways those are
just some of the theories I wanted to
talk about because I really didn't say a
whole lot about them in my trailer
breakdown video I was noticing that some
of you were asking me about them so I
figured this would be a good time to
talk about them most of you should
already know that I want Gendry to
reforge ice at the end of the season
this is something I have been talking
about ever since I started my channel
really also I do think John will ride a
dragon and
like I said I think there is a very good
chance that Nymeria does show up they
already confirmed that we will see some
scenes with ghosts but Nymeria could be
another one of those X factors let me
know what's one of these you think will
end up coming true leave your thoughts
down below in the comment section I want
to thank everyone for watching today's
video I'll really appreciate that and
also want to thank everyone on patreon
for continuing to support the channel I
hope you all have a great day
I will see you again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]